bueno definitivamente
no es muy buena noticia esto aunque ha
ocurrido en tiempos anteriores también
ocurrió con el caso de la implementación
de la ncaa que es el programa que le da
acceso a los jóvenes para poder obtener
este un permiso de trabajo pero esto es
temporal y creemos que tienen suceder en
el estado muy conservador que
acordémonos pues es aquí donde el
senador ted cruz uno de los que se
envalentonaron para la situación de lo
que ocurrió en la toma del capitolio el
estado de texas ha sido un estado muy
conservador y ahorita en el tiempo del
turismo lógicamente este estado se
envalentonó más con las milicias
racistas y eso lógicamente
el hecho de que se suspenda la
deportación de las gentes de las
personas que no tienen ninguna
protección migratoria sí pero que se ha
bloqueado por parte de un fuerza tiene
un estado de texas que instancia legal
sigue y que pueden hacer las
organizaciones defensoras de migrantes
para detener estas deportaciones bueno
siempre ha habido una actividad de calle
siempre vieron actividades de continua y
creemos de que en este momento ya hay un
equipo de abogados especialmente
especializados en el área de inmigración
que han estado trabajando y esto aunque
es temporal
está enviando un mensaje verdad de
oposición a las medidas que está
implementando está tratando de
implementar el presidente bayrén aunque
creemos que este es un lenguaje que se
está utilizando que cambia la temática
que había venido implementando la
administración anterior del 13-d
trump creemos de que esta situación
aunque es temporal pues envía un mensaje
de oposición a todas las órdenes
ejecutivas que está emitiendo el
presidente a bailén pero creemos que la
lucha por parte de la señalización es
continuo